Amber Rose is calling out Dancing with  the Stars judge Julianne Hough her body  shaming  [Music]  amber addressed that clip from this  week's results show on her podcast  Loveline  I did feel body shamed for me and my  body my hips my ass my breasts made her  feel uncomfortable and I lifted my leg  up and it made her uncomfortable and I  felt like it was because my body was too  voluptuous which my body is you know a  normal woman's body I don't know if  really a kind of made me sad a little  bit Julianne has responded to Amber's  podcast telling et in a statement quote  my comments were solely reacting to the  quality of the dance I was judging any  kind of body shaming is the furthest  thing from Who I am and what I stand for